hey reject nation its Greg Alva here
with Brad are Lambert's on Instagram
milk what is it what is the R stand for
it's mine own no name Robert Robert
oh what a simple man yeah it's very
simple I know Brad from the movie
business
I know Brad from Warner Brothers you
might have seen me do a couple a few
gigs and them to the edge of tomorrow
promotion the Gala's haunted house and I
also did the CIA training video for
central intelligence which was awesome
that was awesome Brad and I became
buddies we hung out at Disneyland and
that wasn't long yeah and we missed me
getting thrown up on first oh yeah I was
in line and someone threw up on the hide
what do you have to happen I hated this
guy now we have a kissing ass take your
name
that's my new that's my motto Brad you
were from Warner Brothers right so you
guys produce spider-man homecoming no
yeah that's the way it works you guys
are a marble definitely make sure I get
my facts right no no no we do DC Hills
never heard of them did I stick this on
your shirt Wonder Woman which broke all
the records by the way of jamming team
wrestling sure go my bad what a woman go
see one room I'm gonna do it right now
but this weekend spider-man homecoming
came out so I thought we should do a fun
video where we rank the spider-man
movies I found out from talking with
Brad very briefly about it that we have
the spider-man movies in the exact order
of least favorite to miss Bailey go so
let's kick this off with number six what
was her number six oh yeah the amazing
spider-man 2 you know what a lot of
people gave it a lot of hate but I
personally like Andrew Garfield he's not
my favorite spider-man by any means but
his sarcasm and wit as a you know older
spider-man Peter Parker made it really
enjoyable for me so you actually enjoy
the amazing spider-man 2 yeah I mean
it's not my favorite but I didn't have a
super problem with it and obviously with
the
gwen stacy death in which everybody
remembers it's didn't like a pervert
the gwen stacy desk nothing ever
happened to energy
yeah it's true no it was like that hit
home even though i did wasn't enjoying
the movie area at that time i was like
this is really compact green Goblin's
here yeah she did die i was in the crowd
on and when she hit her head against her
back and head and foreground I went all
and we had is heartbreaking and was it
was Arthur Agee he really felt for that
relationship that they had for each
other
and I've been in that exact situation
second see language second few late do
my weapon I think just fans your well we
don't want to we're not bad yeah I hate
that movie yeah that's why it's
definitely number 605 illa number six
yeah it's still no bill bits with yeah
you're in the thing that John does that
I can't stand all right what is it you
keep twisting and clearing we see arable
I can't look good oh okay not only I
know you're used to being behind the
scene yeah I do yeah so amazing
spider-man to consider the word
obviously number five is probably
everyone guessing for number five what
do we say was Brad D spider-man 3
spider-man 3 you know as much as I put
this film as number five I kind of enjoy
the hell out of it wrapped up is really
against to wrap it up if it had another
note I was really confusing my did he
get to do this yet what the hell
happened at the end of that movie here
at his identity crisis yeah as we all do
which made it really interesting
especially that dance that famous gift
now oh yeah do not only is he dancing
James Franco and Mary Jane Watson or
Banta all he's making it all the way I
think that was the first movie I can
legit remember to complain about for
like three hours straight
who wants the movie was over when you
know we have your film buddy that you
just rent with yeah yeah that was the I
think that was the first movie where I'm
like I've talked about this movie all
night why actually coming off of
spider-man 2 oh yeah which is one of the
best of the best one right it's calling
one of the top one in this one
we saw the trailer for spider-man 3 and
we're like wait a second this this could
be this could be something just good and
venom black leather yeah yeah and then
yeah and then even the emotional moments
sucked I remember when Peter started
crying and everyone with my Peters
throat laughing we shouldn't be laughing
at this right no definitely not laughing
it struggle it's a struggle but the
struggle you want to gain weight for
that scene yeah that's what I do I point
out celebrities in their game you make
it I have no respect for human being I
think I'm a nice fireman too and
spider-man theory could be argued about
what's worse amazing spider-man 2 is
worse as a film yeah but I think if
spider-man 3 is definitely no more
disappointing I agree with that yeah
definitely disappointment especially
coming up to as we already mentioned but
the amazing spider-man 2 just had way
too much going on yeah amazing how they
didn't learn a lesson from spider-man
yeah the ironic part to me but number 4
for us would be the amazing spider-man
yeah amazing spider-man which I know got
a lot of crap before alive we don't want
to see a reboot plot for a plot Uncle
Ben's death origin I surprisingly really
I remember when that movie came out I
was one of the people kind of defending
the film yeah looks like what you said
about Andrew Garfield because one thing
you got to give amazing spider-man 2 is
Andrew Garfield still does a really good
job yeah it's kind of like a really
great performance in a bad film
unfortunately yet I was the caityln I
mean he brought a new dynamic to the
character we didn't see yeah it was dark
and edgy and funny and I like that see
where he's like bullying the criminal
yeah he's kind of abusing the criminal
he and a few scenes are always funny
abuse is a hilarious topic investing
violence said everything like that he
did though he had a new element appear
especially coming off Tobey Maguire's
yeah he was very soft-spoken very
laid-back
this is definitely an edgier beer than
he came before and it was I stuttered a
lot of people gave him a lot of crap for
that but I thought that was a nice
little character saying he had miss
Scheele had to grow yeah and I thought
him and Emma Stone I feel like a lot of
people discredit their chemistry just
because they were
couple that doesn't mean you're going to
be good on camera together you still
need to be a good activity to good
actors working together I would argue
that the chemistry between the two
actors was better than Mary Jane and so
we have our Irish ancestry I'm yeah haha
let's drink the chicken come on I
actually would agree with you on that
like while I think the spider-man 1 & 2
are better films I think the chemistry
between Emma Stone Andrew Garfield is
better so wait six five four okay number
three
wait that is number three wait a minute
Lawrence
oh yeah just--we're Department reflected
ah damn know everything here got it out
to sing well yeah I mean you work for
Marvel I work there's a song it's not
right number three would have to be for
me for both of us I'm so glad we had the
same list number three would have to be
spider-man the Tobey Maguire version Sam
rings the first one the first one I
really loved it so I remember I left
school early that day yeah I brother
pulled me out of school with him and his
ex-girlfriend and that was the day they
broke another foam head at school that
day and we went to go out spider-man and
I had only read the first like couple
origin stories of the Hydra man and then
I watched it and I was blown away it was
one of those songs that when I got older
I realized oh this is kind of campy and
cheesy yeah
but at the time it was perfect to me I
wouldn't have changed a thing at the
time I grew up with the 90s animated
cartoon yeah yeah I was grow Toby did a
great job he really fell into that I
loved it too I remembered I was in the
similar scenario we went to the theater
there was actually a guy dressed up as
spider-man which is cool they were given
out like window clings you know I feel
like when people saw like Superman back
didn't ya like want to fly yeah after
that movie everyone was doing this yeah
and everyone Jana to climb on walls and
break in there oh yeah I'm like yeah I
did I broke many a bones I pulled a
Jeremy Renner yeah that's for sure
sorry too soon too soon that was one
hell of a movie and I
the Green Goblin was scary that first
yet because the movie starts off like it
can't be and cheesy but then there's
some emotional moments like one of my
favorite scenes of all the spider-man
franchise is when Uncle Ben dies and
then he starts going after the criminal
every time I see that scene I'm like
motive thee oh yeah I might feel that
burn him to go do it he went after him
and that was an iconic scene for sure
but out of that you were referencing
Green Goblin in this film and the
performance his name is escaping me
right now Charlie Sheen oh well yeah he
had that film especially when he was
talking to himself in the mirror yeah
that was crazy everybody had that voice
that he would switch to for green
Goblin's beat spider-man yeah and I and
also when he that final fight when ya
does say that yeah that was crazy
because the movies like campy pg-13
fauna until you get to that fight near
like this is kind of like a horror movie
right especially when it's face blue
especially when it's face blue off hey
anyway let's go to our number two so
here we go guys is it homecoming or is
it spider-man 2 actually I think this is
where the the list in fur is my friend
well here's what I'll say what we agreed
to on this list is actually my favorite
spider-man movie that we're putting in
number two however I think the movie
that we're putting is number one is the
best spider-man performance and that's
what we're making it part 1 spider-man 2
is what we have on the list the rest
because so yes swagger Man 2 is
technically my favorite spider-man film
but in terms of ranking the spider-man
movies I'm going to make number one what
I thought was the best spider-man
performance and spider-man 2 that's just
one of my all-time favorite superhero
films to be completely transparent to be
honest with you yeah that never lie
don't lie and I'm not going to lie to
you I'm gonna be truthful he's gonna
tell me that that is one of my favorite
films there was something so moving to
me about it and I feel like some people
kind of don't like that it a lot of it
he's not spider-man actually I met a lot
of people who don't get on board with
the fact that he loses the web powers
and a head doesn't have faith in himself
yeah
some people have issues of that for me I
kind of connected with it because it was
all about you know him finding a firm
foundation in himself and finding a firm
belief in himself and I like the drama
that plays out and it builds up because
by the time we get that famous train
sequence where he's like fighting dock
off and you get to the Train like that
epic sequence then FAC makes ya face
it's very good it about yeah that when
it gets a whole sequence it's all super
rewarding because we had a whole lot of
him not being spider-man it took time to
just be a Peter Parker film here a lot
of it Doc Ock was an amazing villain
that's going with the you know the
octopus tentacle things going berserk
was super Sam Raimi or will be like yeah
the performances right I think that's a
perfect film honestly and because of
that it makes spider-man 3 even worse
this is so good yeah sparked meant to
was was epic
just from start to finish the character
development throughout the entire film
was great you saw Peter in a and a non
confident stage yeah and he lost his
abilities because of it yeah I'm going
to kind of realize that uh wait a second
yeah yeah yeah kinda like a scene in
spider-man homecoming game against the
delegation suggested that but yeah so
number one is obviously spider-man
homecoming like I said before because of
the fact that that is easily the best
portrayal of Peter Parker slash
spider-man that we accurate yeah that
we've ever gotten on the big screen the
most fun enthusiastic yeah even more
layered in my opinion I agree
because yeah while he's like the
funniest version he's still incredibly
layered as a full blown performance
anyone who saw spider-man homecoming
when we talked about the scene you're
talking about the scene where Michael
Keaton took down all the pillars of the
building the roof collapse yeah on Peter
now what's great about this scene is
Peter as a kid in this movie everybody
kind of forgets that they look at Tom
Holland they're like Oh 21 years old in
this film he's 15 years old
so you have a kid who essentially gets
buried alive by the debris of the
building right Tom's performance in that
scene really if he wasn't on the mat
before
he's on the map now just what can you
say the emotion he generated from that
scene fearing for his life yeah he was a
kid
fearing for his life screaming for help
hoping someone who would come and save
him but and he had that moment where he
saw his reflection in the mask and he
was like I'm spider-man and then he went
that epic come on spider-man come on
spider-man can you talk about it you're
talking about like a real person
yeah that's what God invited me killed
suppose it is going yeah it's really
inspiring I like it this is not even a
real payment it was great that was good
yeah because I think he's so hilarious
in the film but that specific scene just
alone shows just how layered it was I
mean we've all been there roofs
collapsing on us yeah it happens all the
time and I'm like I'm Greg I have a
youtube channel and then I drag down I
die and awesome I am becomes amazing but
I will say about this this version of
spider-man and you have a very arrogant
spider-man a kid who knows he can stop a
bus with his bare hands
who knows he can climb buildings and
swing and on Captain America because of
the experiences that led up the
spider-man around I mean he thinks he's
invincible and I thinks he can literally
do anything and throughout the entire
film all he does is make mistakes the
entire time he doesn't do anything right
once yeah
you know he brings the gem to the
monument yeah it explodes
he created the the issue on the ferry
which caused it to split in half no he
didn't do anything right so up to that
point that's when he kind of was
grounded you know I was like you gotta
wake up kid Stark's performance he kept
telling him the whole time was like the
messages you're not ready for this yeah
stay on the ground
they close to the ground you know that's
my formulas like while we're talking
about all the other spider-man films
we're talking about the whole film yep
but when you talk about homecoming you
thought you pretty much talked about Tom
Holland okay you know what makes it
problem oast likely the best spider-man
film can't wait to watch it you saw
three times it yeah there you go
well yeah what are your guys's ranking
of it do you love spider-man homecoming
do you hate us for not having our films
in the exact order you like them to be
in weather here is let's hear it
we know that comic book fans are always
the nicest commentators in the world yes
not judgmental they're not judgmental
they never they never take out the site
but they were nerds who were bullied out
on other people behind a computer screen
that's the coolest thing about it and
they're very supportive very supportive
and they respect other people's opinions
all the time exactly much loved of all
you guys hey subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bill
more importantly though follow Brad our
Lambert on Instagram he does photography
he does he works with Warner Brothers
every time I do a give a Warner Brothers
he's there what do you do there
so I basically manage the campaigns for
our TV and film oh that's what are you
born in they're all the content you see
on social media we have a great team
there for producing that content we try
to give you the best up that represents
our films well so hope you're enjoying
that stuff out of everything I knew
about you that was the one thing I
didn't know about continued only thing I
should have known about it and he
manages and everything he's going to be
managing me in my acting career yeah
there yeah I decided to just ask him on
camera right here right now
honest but I got one sweet we'll make it
happen
look out for me in ten years because I'm
coming your way